last thing I need is my laundry taking
longer I'm already dealing with a low
flow shower head and my kids are coming
out with conditioner smashed to their
head like an old Seinfeld episode and I
have to tell them to get back in and
re-wash I can't even flush my toilet one
time to get toilet paper down because of
the low flow toilets I don't need a low
flow washing machine folks this is more
a segment for a dietitian or
nutritionist Tudor is missing some Fiber
in her diet this isn't about low flow
low flow toilets whose regulations have
not actually changed for a very long
time how on Earth did Republicans get
obsessed with toilets and remember this
all goes back why do right Wingers have
so many Plumbing issues you know with
left-wing people I know
no one ever seems to have an issue with
plumbing Plumbing's working beautifully
uh I'm actually having some Plumbing
work done soon I'm going to ask about
this I'm going to ask my plumber do
Republicans struggle with toilets more
than Democrats